c'est une histoire qui s'invente une
histoire entre eux et nous eux ils ont
été séparés de leur famille est confiée
parfois très jeunes à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
aujourd'hui ils sont adolescents ils
n'ont pas trouvé leur place dans les
foyers blacks sonny foyer d'accueil sont
violents fugueurs déscolarisés ils sont
surnommés ont nommé les uns case à case
oble nous nous sommes éducateur au
psychologue hansen guidé par la détache
de freud de dolto d'olten de bientôt et
de bien d'autres
ensemble nous rêvions d'un lieu
d'accueil et d'écouté pour ces enfants
que la société attend de madame quand le
temps de mal à entendre
nous avons donc créé il ya quelques mois
un lieu de vie expérimental
la croix des quatre chemins
une maison isolée isolé bordée par la
forêt perd son souffle aussi étrange
quand veloppement une nouvelle
respiration respiration pour eux au beau
mais pour nous
[Musique]
mais saurons-nous réellement leur
proposer quelque chose de différent
où sommes-nous juste une année jusqu à
beaulieu dans l'utopie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'arrivée
et voilà la croix des quatre chemins
[Musique]
c'est à droite c'est la chambre de
droite l'a alors le truc aussi bons les
fenêtres je suis ne marche pas sur le
toit c'est pas une bonne idée et en plus
tu vois quand les tuiles sans péter nous
on a ça nous fait des infiltrations
d'eau on a remarqué en dessous donc
voilà c'est pas fait pour ça je l'aï
vécu là-bas très bien donc du coup tu
restes là ok donc la wii la salle de
bain du coûteux celle de marie là aussi
donc tu l'as partage du coup avec yanis
et dylan le lever s'effectue de façon
autonome en fonction des activités au
plus tard à 8 heures 30 en semaine les
repas ils se prennent ensemble dans la
salle à manger et pas de téléphone
portable
le vendredi c'est factures at-on ménage
lorsque celui ci sera fait de l'argent
de poche pourra être distribué la
possession et la consommation d'alcool
et de produits stupéfiants ils formaient
formellement interdite au sein de la
structure
les lois qui s'appliquent dans la
société s'applique dans votre lieu de
vie donc en fait tu voyais à rien de
bien
g mais voilà c'est juste des règles de
vie mais de vie de 100 en société c'est
tout tu as des questions
[Musique]
m
après piloter pour moi tu viens
d'installer mac si huawei un petit pas
battu toi tu prends des médicaments sa
tasse un peu quand même
ouais ça passe est fait du bien quand
même le très lourd
ouais c'est pour toi déjà comme un type
de nouvelle date
c'est quoi ces 32 conflit 223 d'une
enquête franco même bout de leur nez
une petite zone oui je sais que c'est un
aphrodite et du national moi j'en
prenais d'une vidange doivent jouer nue
- ouais mais tu vois ce qui est
rassurant pour maxime dans ce que tu dis
c'était maxime pour l'instant il a
besoin de prendre les salles tu as un
peu mais c'est vraiment ça fait aucun
traitement et de galilée encore plus
maintenant ça veut dire que si ça veut
tout et les tournages train mais
beaucoup plus fort sur ouais j'avais à
côté
une fois l'échangé de traitement entre
jamais trouvé le bon c'est quoi le truc
que tu parles être le terrain je me tape
les tout seul tu crois quoi ressemble un
peu tout seul
ah oui ça ne faisait pas dit s'il ya des
contre indications avec ces médicaments
est un bon gars mais contre moi-même
insultait je me frapper crowley
parce que tu entendait des voix des
chaussettes non mais je m'égare de moi
même est en colère après travail je vais
pas me supporter la prime est content
comme ça prévient on sait que c'est
quelque chose que tu connais tout le
monde
ouais j'ai terry qui n'avait comme ça
m'empêche de tableaux coûts de structure
bon ben si tu verras les adultes ne
fonctionne pas comme ça n'oubliez pas
non travaillées réclame encore les gars
moi je sors d'une douleur muette douleur
ne tient donc aux ben dis donc ça c'est
pas le thème pourquoi rien c'est pas
elle
j'écoute d'incidents comme on dit mais
moi je tuerai je veux écouter un
marchand si vous êtes avec les pieds
parce que j'ai l'impression de parler à
tes pieds ça mais on est cool merci
maîtrise des proches m'ont souvent fait
ce reproche est le pam confiance et mes
douleurs reste romuald jetons pas voulu
confier de peur que gilbert daniel
sulliger sin frais ce matin
il arrive même que j'en pleure je m'en
fous jacques laporte quel homme à bout
de nerfs le fait alors je m'accroche
bref c'est sous le d'existence j'accepte
et je me prosterne qui n'opère que peu
de résistance
c'est vrai je ne sais pas trop ce qui
m'attend je verrais bien mais j'ai
appris à ne pas compter son absence les
souffrances me serviront laissez moi
juste le temps de comprendre pourquoi
elle frappe de plein fouet et que ça
brûle dans mon ventre pourquoi le mal ne
m'a jamais quitté mais ces toiles donc
derrière ça qu'un de mes sourires il ya
mis peur en toile de fond
[Musique]
à
cabestan limite est un berger tond titi
c'est mon premier texte chez des
fabricants je rappelle d'accord il dit
je m'attaque est à dire en même temps
quand tu vis et je sort demain à 2,11 et
la guerre 15h15 c'est c'est fini en bas
du bed 13 banks en train d'allumer un
joueur c'est un pétard pas bon choix
ben j'en pense que l'avancé de la prime
mon père qui après dix ans et la
commandite sans réplique tea party bel
et bien c'est un peu plus calme un peu
plus posé plus comment je faisais qui
ont tapé tapé tout en décembre où tu
t'appelles tu te faisais taper deux sens
un an m enfin donné tu t'en prends comme
franck bonnet est effet la banque de la
rue tout le temps utile un arrêt des
combats dont je connais ça fait mal ya
pas de règles
jardi titre d'affilée je vous aime a
presque plus de partir un petit peu en
vacances mais je reviens moi après je
suis là toutes les semaines du jeudi
soir jusqu'aux cintres
on fait plus on parle quand on n'a pas
de bureau et sicce pas de rendez-vous
d'accord monsieur c'est comme s'il veut
continuer à la fois dur et si tu veux je
sais pas si un troisième vélo ville
année un troisième vélo si ces
adolescents n'ont pas choisi d'être
confié à la zone l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
en revanche ils ont fait le choix d'être
ici aux quatre chemins et d'en accepter
l'esprit nous nous sommes sept adultes
nous relayer jour et nuit pour faire
vivre l'esprit familial de cette maison
nous n'avons pas de protocole éducatif
nous improvisons à chaque instant chez
eux tout nous parle
leur comportement est un langage qui
nous racontent qu'ils sont il faut juste
avoir du temps celui d'un quotidien
partager les biens sont allés un nom
dylan ne fait pas rire
non mais là ça me fait pas rire du tout
tu le sais un chabrol banon mais même si
c'est bien comment j'aime pas ça bien
l'on soit si bon c'est pierre conscien
ça moi j'ai sursauté j'ai le coeur qui
bat à 15000 si tu peux pousser le
bordeaux maxime steuplé sus un des chips
à nant cover des chips qu'on est avec
les haricots verts ah non il n'y a pas
ça il ya des chips non non rien n'a pas
maxime ces cantons analystes c'est bien
pour notre liste
ah oui mais toi tu es comme je m'y
attendais ong les informations plein et
être j'écoute inquiète
ok je veux dire la truyère
ce soir je vais avec les poteaux à faire
une petite f sur un anniversaire
tranquille posé sur le canapé toujours à
15 ou là quand les condés arrivants
galopent en garde prêter à leurs chiens
pour encore rencontrer sa famille sur un
contre les gadgi rappelle moi je
t'aiderai et 06 secondes et 06 - les
gardiens ça veut dire les filles et tu
donnes les 0,6 des filles et fils et pas
des objets ni dont ça se vend pas ça
qu'est ce que c'est que cette position
mais difficilement x men et c'est pas
une chute banon à citizens est achevée
sur un président était attendu vers
musée par trois heures une bo bobo
donc ça va un peu trop motivé comme en
2001 tu peux pas parler des femmes comme
ça tu te rends pas compte
j'ai tué une femme et les mécènes en
coin qu'ils font n'est pas chère à l'ina
dans la cuisine c'est quoi ce teaser léo
l'égalité je lui dis je serai patient à
témoin sur un seul coup j'entends
quelque chose qui me déplaît beaucoup vu
un truc us à se contrôler deux promus
ben monsieur même si et pas de promesses
moi je suis alors dit m sais-tu
m'arrache pas petit noir en crottes de
bons croix de bois croix de fer croix de
fer si je mens si je mens je m'enferme
enfer je connais pas nous faire mais moi
j'irais pas d'accord je vais voter en
personne
alors sauf si c'est quelque chose de
très grave alors attends que je vais te
dire un truc ya des choses sur
lesquelles je peux absolument rien
répéter il ya une seule chose que je
suis tenue de répéter partout et ça
c'est vrai pour toutes les personnes
tous les adultes de la terre c'est si tu
me dis que tu as été victime de quelque
chose de très grave par un adulte
non
[Musique]
ah bah oui puis en plus ce qui est bon
il ya eu quand même des propos qui vous
ont échappé qu'ils l'ont quand même
particulièrement heurté votre fils je
crois qu'il ya aussi saccagé légitimer
un petit peu alors je dis pas que c'est
justifié
mais le fait qu'il était très en colère
parce que vous avez une réaction aussi
avec des mots complexes à la garde sa
maman oui mais ça c'est des réactions
classique vous vous essayez de vous
décalez un petit peu tout ça que vous
ayez cette colère lasse assez vous avec
votre ex compagne mais c'est votre fils
il a rien à faire là dedans c'est pas ça
c'est pas sa question
oui oui vous êtes tout à fait capable de
lui dire que c'est une histoire de vent
et que c'est pas ben vas là-bas vous je
vous donne la réponse
vous l'avez vous l'avez d'accord bon est
ce que vous voulez parler à votre fils
il est là il est à côté
d'accord mais je pense qu'il est il veut
plus que bien et sans se prendre la tête
il a fait la demande je vous le passez à
bientôt puis on essaiera de regarder sur
la demande que vous avez fait d'accord
je regarderai ça quand je reviens
allez-vous passer en voir bonne soirée à
l'eau ça va
[Musique]
ok
mallet m'appelle plus il espère michel
il est en colère je pense que vous avez
dû voir un échange de mots assez
intéressant on apparaître toute ma vie
depuis que chine en fait ouais t'as une
histoire après moi j'ai pas tous les
éléments mais lui dans ce qu'il a
expliqué
effectivement il a été co il s'est senti
obligé puis je pense qu'il a peut-être
pas eu trop le choix il a eu peur il a
il a appelé les services sociaux pour
qu'il vienne filer un coup de main quoi
mais après c'est pas lui qui a décidé il
ya des gens qui appellent ça bouge pas
du tout c'est pas lui qui a demandé un
placement ça après ça se fera mais c'est
pas ma mère de plus il dit tout le temps
c'est bien lui
mais c'est ni ma mère ceni louise il a
juste mais ça serait bien d'en discuter
avec lui vraiment raconte ce qui s'est
passé quoi peut-être même avec ta maman
parce qu'elle aussi est là après ce que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui peut-être pas
trop envie d'aborder le sujet avec ta
mère non je préfère déjà d'un con qu'on
arrive à mieux dialoguer des problèmes
que c'est quand je parle de ça ça me
pousse sur les nerfs et les voilages et
paris tu prends une montée est un caban
visite avec ma mère non je pense qu'elle
a aussi une histoire
alors là on peut évoquer qui était quand
même pas simple quoi donc voilà il sait
aussi des conséquences mais justement un
jour toi t'es pas là pour reproduire
tous à un moment donné faut sans parler
dire voilà il ya ça ça mais après tout
si tu veux aussi des réponses aussi toi
tu sois ouvert ce que tu sois prêt à
entendre des choses
[Musique]
deux petites vites vous avez fait quoi
map et évite la vitre du coup il y avait
un téléphone maison que je comprends pas
si j'ai déjà été un tribunal pour ça bat
a été mise en examen ce pour ça mais
c'est comme si c'était réglé
ah non la mise en examen ça veut juste
dire en a pris note de ça on te met en
examen ça veut dire qu'on jugera ton
truc plus tard je pense qu'à la question
c'est de se dire est ce qu'aujourd'hui
il dit yann piat devant vous c'est le
même c'est à dire qu'ils revoient la
voiture avec l'ipod est ce qu'il répète
la vitre ou pas voilà c'est aussi ça
c'est là c'est ça qui les intéressent
mois
[Musique]
à
je voulais vous faire un point sur le
l'audience qui s'est tenue
jeudi audience quedal pénale pour dylan
en fait donc il était jugé pour deux
affaires une affaire de vol qui s'est
passé en mai avant qu'ils arrivent chez
nous et puis la plainte suite à la
plainte aussi toutes les dégradations
qu'ils avaient commis chez nous il a
reconnu reconnaît aussi qu'il ya des
fois il a du mal à gérer sa frustration
et voilà que c'est que c'est compliqué
mais surtout fin voilà donc du coup il a
prit alors le jugement est arrivé il a
pris un intime de 30 heures et il reste
beaucoup à faire
moi j'en ai compté 2 3 encore une semble
ont expliqué à ma mère je me fais
attention parce que le juge pour
l'instant il est conscient il est
d'accord sur le fait que l'on voit des
choses donc il accepte et une pièce
d'anton dossier des choses qui traînent
par contre le jour où le juge décide que
ça suffit il fait tout tombé d'un coup
il a plutôt intérêt finalement de se
remettre dans le droit chemin entre
guillemets pour que sa place plutôt juge
quoi il retourne en valais quoi ce sera
tout en cette heure du tout
à tout à l'heure
bonne journée sa place mondiale via
lattea jean-pierre seychelles le début
voulais pas les garder c'est moi j'ai
jadis est mort on les gars ça me fait du
mal les voir d'or 2010 relève pas loin
de les faire entrer quoi
dans tous les autres foyers que j'ai
eues j'étais c'était c'était la joie de
la jungle c'était l'avis du plus fort
quoi
du coup il y avait tous les jours ça se
bat et se respecter par au scratch et
humour se taper dessus
je me rappelle même un premier foyer on
me réveillant cracher dessus en
m'étranglant de taper et j'avais 8 ans
c'est dur mais bon faut accepter après
vos débuts j'étais pas bien ici je
n'étais pas bien je lui dis ça va être
la fois une merde comme tous les autres
que j'ai fait et au final non c'est pas
le cas parce que une super sucre au fur
et à mesure du temps c'est vrai qu'ils
aient beaucoup de choses pour moi
puisque je commencerai micha et puis
voici jjp as accorde une seconde chance
quoi
je me suis pas une fois je me dis après
normal j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit ça
rien à part bas par rapport plus dans
merde ça ça un jeu c'est surtout partie
finir à la rue quoi j'ai beaucoup de
potes à moi qu'il n'en voyez qu'ils ont
fini la robe et le puits ou à la juste
res tous les voyants stress sony 09 qui
l'aurai toute ma vie
[Musique]
oh
la croix des quatre-chemins sylvain
bonjour oui ouais ouais j'allais vous à
pleyben il ya en fait maxime or portant
de la prison au début était très content
moi de la visite et où sa voix la voix
tout à fait et quelques minutes après
sur la route qui s'en est pris à mon
collègue qui refusait de s'arrêter dans
un magasin pour lui acheter un téléphone
portable
donc mon collègue a pas pu faire
autrement que de s'arrêter en urgence
sur la route s'est passé pas loin d'un
accident de ski à une voiture derrière
et puis après maxime a demandé ce que
les gendarmes soient appelés donc
gendarmes sont intervenus maxime a été
conduit à l'hôpital à avallon ils ont
gardé quelques instants en lui donnant
un médicament je sais plus non voilà
c'est un axe qui a permis de le calmer
et il a dormi sur tout le trajet du
retour
tout à fait je comprendrais
[Musique]
ce qu'on peut peut-être faire ce soir
c'est vous rappeler avec natacha un très
bien alors 20 des gages à les noms aussi
aller aux débats aux martyrs
le ski le temps pour chiens steve est un
jeu sportif qu'est ce qui se passe
député de plants de fines et alpha média
j'ai peur bon bah oui mais quand tu as
été marton papa on prendra peut-être du
temps pour en parler
je pense qu'on va portable et je
voudrais que tu prennes ton traitement
ce survival prendre le chat potté mis
d'accord et oui monsieur pas plus ouais
je sèche pas très ponton tour seront
[Musique]
noir imprimé et demi dont en france on
est couché
de quoi inciter à 15h et à l'élu nom
maxime je prends plus jamais a promis
que prend avec des pistes ont le plus
envie de me battre avec toi non non tu
le fais mais non parce que si on
s'arrête là ça va être n'importe quoi le
peuple sahraoui
elle est en confiance non non c'est pas
une histoire de confiance à son instinct
pas le faire bastia pas faire c'est que
il ya un tube à la factory tels que tu
as rencontré un petit peu comme ça s'est
passé ton papa qui m'a contrat là on
peut
ouais
plus ça avance et puis vous montre aussi
comment une fois il est il est pris par
quelque chose qui le dépasse ben oui
c'est sain et du coup il un vrai
traitement qu'on donne dans des services
alors il a pris ce soit et du coup ce
type de traitement c'est pas pour rien
qu'on les donne en il répond de la
psychiatrie maintenant votre fils vous
voyez quelque chose qui est une réalité
complexe quoi ouais enfin c'est pas si
banal que ça coince et des médicaments
lourds un qui prend pas pour rien ben
pas forcément justement l'idée c'est
qu'ils retrouvent de la ressource
autrement sans être débordé son devenir
dangereux pour lui et pour les autres
pour pouvoir lever ce type de traitement
quoi mais effectivement s'il devient
trop dangereux ça peut être complexe et
après l'issue bas pour certains faux pas
sûrs et sains s'il ya un acte grave qui
est posée au bout d'un an c'est les murs
qu'ils arrêtent
ouais c'est dur à entendre ce qu'on sent
on retravaillera mais c'est pas facile
d'entendre ça quand on est une maman
entend c'est une réalité qui agit de
votre fils et c'est peut-être aussi
important que vous l'entendez qu'on vous
dise les choses enfants quoi ça a
commencé un petit gars un petit bout de
temps à m'annonça et d'un seul coup il
ya quelque chose qui est partie en vain
ça a été un déclencheur d'accord
non super et puis on se laisse le temps
c'est à dire quoi si on voit que c'est
long c'est trop long je sais pas quoi on
s'autorise que c'est à dire pas
forcément le temps officiel peu importe
le prompteur d'accord les décès
peut-être plus court mais bien que très
long et avec des temps où un moment ça
c'est un peu ça peut empêcher tout le
monde d'accord bon on se voit demain je
vous en prie bonne soirée madame brand
va
dites-nous droite
tir jack sim chez sa maman quelque chose
alors j'ai une icône y allez devoir
comprendre un temps pour tout le monde
l'attend un montant atteint 32 - yoga
est en train de te parler maxi je marque
je vous ai dit qu'on resterait le temps
qu'on pouvait et puis si on sent quand
même on peut plus bas du coup on sera
d'accord
elle sera l'un disait que l'on peut lui
faire un tour vous allez faire jour tu
as les marchés matures que aller en
voiture
bah ouais la voiture la nuit je peux te
faire un petit tour ne pas cantonner
j'aime pas confirmer ce que je vois que
l encre ou mort ah non j'ai pas envie
d'aller boire un coup bas comme on peut
le joindre en voiture sur ce fait faire
un petit show man petites choses que je
vois que dalle à nîmes un accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je peux pas le contrôler tu veux
rappeler en armes
mais le bagne en attendant c'est que je
vois pas pourquoi
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on fasse avec
l'agent je les appelais ce de relâcher
tribus alors j'ai pas vu leurs frappes
et j'ai déjà posé du pouce et
physiquement ou verbalement et puisque
j'ai toujours j'ai pas une montée de
frapper où et pourquoi quand on vient de
se poser tranquillement homme seul ait
traversé le mur
qu'est-ce que tu kiffes rc lens je tique
mais attention
et la presse que tu vas là et bonne
chère est où le problème
les quartz
si je le fera parce que vous avez
débarqué des flets quelqu'un on est là
le lieu de la dernière chance c'est vrai
ça qu'on a besoin de nous parce que tous
les ados porte chance et les adolescents
dont joël bats jour de chance vous
regarde pas prédire aujourd'hui deux
fois moins je dis mais qu'est ce que tu
souhaites met en garde à vue tu veux
rentrer en prison toi aussi
et du coup m'a dit oui mais ça aurait
été trop facile de dire comme ton papa
quoi parce que ça aurait été trop rapide
quoi ça aurait été trop collé mais il ya
quelque chose comme ça où il visite son
père en prison
il appelle du fiqh en permanence et il
ya quelque chose chez nuit ou dans
l'imaginaire ça viendrait bordé pour la
réaliser certainement juste mais ce qui
est difficile
ça va être deux buts de vivre au
quotidien avec ce type de pression
effectivement indexing a répondu soit
aujourd'hui la nous donne à voir qui
répondu sont plus que de l'étiquette il
faut journée le choix oui du soin moi je
suis la maman de maxime au téléphone
aujourd'hui je vais la visite médiatisée
j'ai commencé à amorcer avec elle l'idée
qu'elle a
enfin quelqu'un malade il a tous les
sites cliniques du patient qu'on peut
avoir nous à l'hôpital avec des
débordements les effractions encore les
angoisses massilia temps de lui même
alors dans ce cas là on n'est plus dans
un lieu de vie on va dire qu'on est dans
un hôpital ti ben oui est-ce qu'on est
armé est ce qu on est armés nous je vais
dire formés pour ça c'était la
discussion que j'avais hier et natacha
et moi je dis moi on était super sport
neige pays 3 il ya aucune chance aux
pics élevés ya aucune n'a aucune place
et en plus de pratiquants qui si on peut
pas tout traiter c'est plus de notre
domaine sinon pas de place c'est pas
notre problème je m'en fous ils
trouveront une solution et c'est pas
normal puisque du coup on met en danger
sciemment je pense que l'équipe et voir
même les gardiens au trou qu'on sait pas
ce qui peut se passer
miles en souffrance non on pourra pas
les risques restent français a tout de
suite
la situation est compliquée certes elle
n'est pas désespérée il faut essayer de
prendre différemment c'est on est dans
le travail là c'est vrai qu'il faut
qu'on construise une solution pour lui
avant tout et aussi en même temps par
ricochet pour nous pour que pour que ça
reste que ça reste vivable et concentré
concerne repas avec lui un de les
traiter à table c'est une plus cela n 4
6 jeunes rappeurs les ce qui m'intéresse
c'est l'arabe il perd un peu à mon
argent parlera pas ici de
d'enregistrement est un peu de basket
complaisez artistes chantent que ça
j'ai des problèmes qui arrivent ma tête
et que j'arrive pas à parler ça peut
être plus souvent l'habitude coin de ma
tête je me dire calme-toi arrêté mon
corps qui prend déchets c'est
s'abattront sur vous mais aussi de s'en
sortir car c'est sur son soirée eh eh
bien j'avais jamais je ne m'en sortirais
jamais inhumaines enfants qui ont essayé
d'en sortir
je vais partir
derrière ces adolescents mal de vivre
il ya souvent des mères des pères des
générations entières qui se débattent
avec leur propre existence
alors si nous devons continuer du mali
ces jeunes sur le chemin de l'apaisement
il nous faut aussi être à l'écouté de
leurs proches être des médiateurs pour
faire émerger une parole réparé pas à
pas les liens abîmée
c'est un présent
[Musique]
c'est mon patron qu'une laisser mon
contrat je te mets à sauver le delta
sauter le taf leur laisse tomber ouais
c'est pas contre culture d'alors
l'atlantide et voir la copine voiture je
suis pas très à l'aise avec sardines
pourquoi bas parce que pour la connais
pas on sait pas qui sont connaît pas les
parents m'a dit si tu veux dire merci
oui mais on peut le préparer avant on
prépare à prouver qu'elle n'a que ça
fait deux semaines
alors ça oui 10 - oui c'est son âge et
ya deux semaines joueur devra attendre
plusieurs teintes sa ville anne qu'on
parle un peu de tout ça là bas sur c'est
pas possible tu sers dit c'est moi c'est
ce que je t'avais dit un dylan un truc
moi qui met hors de moi c'est la
confiance
quand j'entends mener ya quinze jours
c'est beaucoup de gens qui étaient quand
même pas très d'accord sur le fait que
je te dépose là bas j'ai joué le jeu et
tout s'est joué le jeu en disant ah là
je lui fais confiance et je me suis
retrouvée jusqu'à 2h30 du matin bataille
est bien trop que ça m'a fait rire moi
de voir les les gendarmes le menottaient
c'est grave ce qui s'est passé c'est pas
un truc pas grave quoi dans une vie quoi
depuis tu crois que je mesure pas les
conséquences que ça va avoir pour toi
tout ça et même le matin tu arrives pas
à trouver à tenir à carreau ce matin
c'est à trente secondes de crever [__]
surtout qu'il ya ressorti m'avait dit
voilà t'inquiète je me lève pas de
soucis machin je me suis dit allez je
fais confiance je me dis qu'il va se
lever tu vois
bingo ce matin refait la même quoi tu
vois
[Musique]
la question c'est comment
on récupère la confiance de l'autre
voiture la confiance de personnes
sifflent c'est faux on a tous besoin
d'avoir confiance en quelqu'un si on n'a
pas confiance il n'y a pas d'amour
dizaines
[Musique]
sais pas de quoi tu as peur j'arrête un
nombre d'atouts pour toi tu es un gamin
brillant tu sais faire plein de trucs
dillon qu'est ce qui fait que ça va si
mal
qu'est ce qui te rend si malheureux quoi
[Musique]
la question du cadre et de la règle elle
et elle vient les solliciter sur comment
je vais m'inscrire d'encadrer la dans
l'arène et dylan il était à sa gran
trade dans il a tout fait exploser quoi
moi je vais du plu enfin je pense
vraiment dylan que tu as peur de réussir
ta peur de réussir et dis moi vos
petites règles d'un bon j'en veux pas et
en fait il nous énonce aussi qui sont
alors c'est pas quand on analyse là où
ils en sont ce qui nous donne à voir au
travers des règles c'est aussi nous
faire attention à pas être juste des
applicateurs de règles et puis dire il
m'annonce haye et correspondent aux
boules et ils sont guéris quoi là ça va
être
on sera à côté de la plaque et moi je
travaille pas comme ça quoi je suis pas
là pour l'adresser ça m'intéresse pas
parce que dans tout ce qui bouscule là
ils viennent justement quand on dit on
parle de l'affectif leurs questions
c'est l'affectif cnnc ça c'est comment
ils savent pas faire avec des sentiments
comment ils se sont trouvés avec des
sentiments d'adultes qui se sont fait
péter la gueule ou on les a insultés où
on leur a dit bah en fait on veut pas de
toi tu es là mais ça me fait vraiment
chier
et eux ils composent avec ça et ça dans
tous les petitesses qui font la clope le
la bouffe le machin de remplissage ça
fait partie de mes outils c'était
prétexte c'est des outils de lecture
c'est pas dire qu'il faut pas faire
tenir le 15 mai nous faut être vigilant
à allait analyser un petit peu plus loin
que le bout de notre nez quoi c'est à
dire ramener aussi cette dimension
inconsciente qui les anime
il ya de l'inconscient dans la vie quand
elle vous jettez soir déjà
et puis on attend les autres dylan yanis
c'est une bombe a du coup là on va on
avait dit qu'on ferait une petite
réunion il y avait une demande d'abord
que tu es parti de temps dylan qui était
de travailler sur avait posé la question
des règles qui voulait reprendre deux
trois choses avec nous en sachant ouais
c'est celle à kiev alors vas-y c'est
l'argent de poche alors là je coche
qu'est ce que tu veux leur dire de cet
argent bac c'est quand même bête qu'est
ce qu'il veut de plus nous donner en
liquide ah parce que ok ok août avait
peur qu'on achète des substances et tout
mais bon on fait pas que ça non plus
avec un voire d'étendre la plupart du
temps avec mon argent de poche j'achète
mes clopes basque riche que ce qui fait
que du coup va au lieu de les acheter
toinon les achètera voilà mais c'est m
on n'est pas des lapins de trois
semaines non plus quoi on a bien compris
comment ça se gérait un petit peu le
truc c'est à dire fin de semaine le
produit y en a moins
et dans le week-end il ya quelqu'un qui
va se déplacer et qui ramène de quoi
pouvoir la semaine suivante
donc effectivement et comme ce genre
produit ça s'achète avec du liquide
parce que ou alors vraiment vous
puissiez le puissiez négocier que les
tablettes de chocolat ou de l'oasis au
casse
vous vous dévoyez à la gare à peut-être
que ça marche
et en fait quand on fait ça c'est aussi
pour vous pointez le fait qu'on n'est
pas d'accord avec ça ici c'est pas une
prison donc le fait est que ça continue
de votre consommation à les lie on la
voit et on n'accepte pas pour autant et
du coup il ya un moment où comme tout
parent il même si on n'est pas vos
parents l'entente très bien ont trouvé
une solution pour vous protéger malgré
vous vous êtes mineur jusqu'ici tout le
monde dans l'eau c'est plus facile
ces actions font au cas par cas ça va
être trop complexe il va y avoir des
négociations il y aura à nouveau de la
circulation d'argent des échanges c'est
à dire je te donne ça tu veux tu me le
paye parce que toi tu as eu du liquide
et donc c'est niet
même si on voulait pas me faire
confiance à un poste moi je consomme pas
offert de confiance ben voilà toi c'est
dans les deux voilà on est tous merci
beaucoup maxi ça fait du bien d'entendre
ça non seulement il yad'autres ghislaine
des non non non non il ya deux trucs tu
restes avec nous là parce que c'est un
peu facile
zidane dit la balle est bonne parce que
aussi vous avez des trucs à sinon on a
oublié
[Applaudissements]
ça s'appelle le lave vaisselle alors la
vaisselle il avait été demandée parce
que faire la vaisselle
[Musique]
les îles fidji la plupart du temps
j'assumais bien souvent je n'en peux
plus déclare pourtant quand j'étais
enfant qui était toujours dans la nuit
la différence c'est peut-être qu'à cette
époque je ne fumais pas juste une clope
sur la nuit celtique après la désormais
célèbre voiture bloquée après il ya le
mot cruel
les deux aînées qu'est ce que tu vas
pour en mettre là-dedans parce que je
comprends que le mot qui va pouvoir mais
les nations prennent at est pas mal mais
sans tuer à cenon alors c'est pas le bon
tu là sinon c'était pas comme truc mais
tu as un autre il ya une autre fois tu
vas retrouver le verbe être qu'il y
aille au st ouais alors tu peux rien le
début de la phrase des deux n'ait été
créés et rés alors comment le pourrait
être connaissent ça pourrait marcher les
ai pas écrit il faut trouver un mot qui
se terminant avec un s
voilà vas-y c'est quoi ce mot un saint
simon wells calvet c'est faire du mal
aux gens
bon tu me diras beach bah non c'est toi
tu voulais qu'on parle d'histoire
d'appart alfos j'aimerais près d'ici
ouais mais en même temps tout seul je
peux faire un peu ce que je la pose est
est il d'accord mais inquiète pas oui
voilà mon nom est ce que tu vaux si ça
veut dire ton ménages' voilà je rentre
tout seul site à vis du monde là bas il
faut qu'on le sache et ça c'est un
projet qu'on avait dit inquiète et jaune
mais ça veut dire aussi bas peut-être
que tu pourrais reprendre des stages tu
vas sortir choses comme ça on pourra le
véhicule et donc tu te verrai quand la
au mois de septembre là partout pas
comment tu te vois les choses toi le
plus vite possible le plus vite possible
après il ya une réalité de temps un tu
le sais quand même un peu morne tout
seul le zoo le juge
bah oui mais les dilemmes nous on est
juste là pour accompagner au mieux et
faire en sorte que toute cette histoire
de juge d eux s'arrêtent petit va être
majeur mais pas que ça s'arrête d'un
coup
toi tu es 18 ans où tu te retrouves dans
la rue comme cela on voit apparaître en
ce moment les jeunes tu vois moi ça me
plaît pas de voir des gamins à la rue et
tout s'est arrêté du côté de la ze et
ils ont plus rien tu as donc ils sont
ils sont dehors
il s'est quand même pas un milieu rigolo
la rue donc l'idée c'est qu'on arrive à
maximum à préparer donc là il faut que
tu nous as mais on a déjà parlé de
salies d'accord
[Musique]
salut tout le monde
voilà un an que le lieu de vie de la
croix des quatre chemins et ouvert il
est temps pour moi ça n'est pas
forcément à ce que nous avions chacun
imagine et nous avons eu une
construction et des débuts très
difficiles et très éprouvant qui ont
entraîné tension idc pour ce travail
j'ai pu avoir des satisfactions à voir
que ce que je projetais dans ce lieu
dans cette scop pouvait parfois se
réaliser puis il ya eu un couac une
fatigue et pillé lurette quoique une
fatigue sourde qui s'est installé dans
ma sphère privée des phrases ironiques
sur un manque de disponibilité à
domicile ont émergé pour me faire
souligné que je ne vivais plus chez moi
je me suis mise à fondre en larmes
dès que je me retrouvais en compagnie de
mes proches ou en pensant à eux ne
voulant rien montrer mon corps
aujourd'hui est tendue et n'arrive pas à
se détendre
aujourd'hui je ne souhaite plus
continuer cette aventure et je pense que
cette aventure est une chance pour ceux
qui veulent la faire vivre et la
continuer me concernant mon corps ma
tête m'alerte avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard pour moi je me suis réellement
investi et je peux dire que j'ai
sacrifié une partie de moi dans ce lieu
bien sûr je ne serais pas vous laisser
du jour au lendemain et pense qu'il faut
que je puisse aider à la transition pour
ce lieu cette structure puisse continuer
à vivre car nous avons montré qu'il y
avait un besoin réel besoin et surtout
une réelle utilité dans ce projet voilà
il y à toute l'étendue de nos
convictions
certes mais il ya aussi la fatigue et la
peur découragement il ya nos propres
histoires préhistoire et la résonance et
les murs de cette maison ne peuvent tout
absorber alors nous devons comme ces
adolescents transformer les ruptures
douloureuses en d'acceptable séparation
et poursuivre nos chemins pour suivre
nos chemins après avoir mangé viser les
étoiles
ça fait pas peur ça c'était la lune fait
quoi comme lasagnes
j'aimerais bien savoir ouais bien il
fait bien débrouillé vie nicolas oui
bonjour quel j'y suis attaché à vue des
quatre chemins tu te rappelles on s'est
rencontrés la dernière fois vendredi
dernier
tu te souviens bon du coup j'ai ma
collègue qui m'a dit que tu allais site
avait appelé à 17 heures bon donc on se
compte a dit c'est que nous on était
prêt à accueillir alors on a réfléchi à
une date
donc je pense que ça serait le 24 ouais
on m'a préparé mais on va préparer ça
avec des éducateurs et puis sur le lieu
d'accord donc tu fais pas tout péter tu
ne t'attends qu'on arrête de chercher
des seuils de très bien un peu d'accord
ok bon alors ça va être un début du
chemin d'accord ok bah je te souhaite
une belle soirée
à bientôt telus kenji non mais pas ceux
qui venaient nous sommes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
ce qu'il restera de tout cela nous n'en
savons rien car si nous arrive de leur
offrir ce qui nous arrive de leur offrir
des réponses ils sont les seuls à
détenir une solution
[Musique]
bon